imagine remembering every single day of
your life
all in perfect detail
for those with highly superior
autobiographical memory or h sam for
short
this is their reality
[Music]
i remember everything that's personally
happened to me since i was born
that's rebecca sharok i was fascinated
by this condition so i called her up to
find out more
hi rebecca hi
how are you going i'm doing all right
it's a very wet saturday morning here
how are you going
side note in this moment i just realized
rebecca will remember that this day was
a wet morning forever
so you remember everything in great
detail people can remember what they did
last saturday but i can remember
what i did saturday 10 years ago
what about a memory from when you were
just a baby
when
i was 12 days old i was lying down on
the fur car seat in my parents car and i
was staring up at the steering wheel and
i thought
what is that rebecca is one of only 60
people worldwide to have been identified
with having hsn all through my teenage
years
i
thought that everybody remembered in
this kind of way i thought it was
completely normal it wasn't until she
was 21 when her parents decided to
submit her to the university of
california to undergo two years of
testing after this she was officially
identified as having h sam
since memories can come to mind
unexpectedly any time of day a negative
memory like this can make living with
hsn difficult
mum was putting me in this itchy satin
dress and i was crying because i didn't
like it and mum gave me this minnie
mouse toy and i couldn't say anything at
the time but her face terrified me
but on most days htm is a gift rebecca
can recall happy memories and moments
when times get tough
a good memory that makes me so thankful
about having this kind of
hsn memory
thanks for chatting rebecca yep thanks
bye
[Music]
you